[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to another
English language lesson today we will
focus on uh a very interesting part of
reading comprehension and we're going to
uh detect logical fallacies in uh the reading
passages that we've been covering in the past
videos uh so let's move on as you can see
here in the video uh and you can understand
from the same words that some uh passages
and some statements or claims or opinions
are uh not to make sense so they don't they
don't make sense that's why they're called
fallacies uh the objectives of this lesson uh are
three and uh the first one is that by the end of
the class the student are are are going to make
the difference are going to see the difference
between uh a statement and opinion and a fact
second one is that students are going to spot
logical fallacies in a uh students perspective
maybe perhaps an academic writing and reading
passages and speaking and listening as well and
the third objective is uh that students are going
to be able to uh write a paper that doesn't use
logical fallacies and know how to fix papers that
do so uh the first one we will focus on uh
introducing the term logical fallacy what
are some common logical fallacies and uh we're
going to put that knowledge into practice uh
by the end of the video uh being persuasive in a
communication process is a tough job especially
if you're a student you need the right amount of
Art in terms of delivery and the right amount of
Integrity in your words and their context and uh
not being able to properly deliver a message is
nothing compared to not having Integrity in
what you say so in this lesson we will learn
how to spot logical fallacies in communication
in writing and reading and why not figure out
why they are wrong so we don't have to uh make
the same mistakes when we uh right or speak to
someone uh so a broad a broad definition of
logical fallaces is uh known to be as a common
flaw so those are common flaws in reasoning that
weaken or uh invalidate someone's arguments logic
and and fallacies can be either invalid arguments
or irrelevant points and they are frequently
discovered due to the absence of evidence to
support the assertion and a good communicator
is able to recognize and uh understand why that
logic doesn't work or what why is that a fallacy
uh as well as uh good communicators are able to
uh avoid falling victim to a logical fallacy some
of the most common logical fallacies are Hasty
generalization slippery slope ad hominy and red
hering Hasty generalization is uh a conclusion
that is based on insufficient evidence or
information uh this logical fallacy is
committed when a uh conclusion is drawn
from a haste or uh an insufficient evidence
and uh uh if we can take an example here uh
let's say that restaurant serves chicken
sandwiches I've heard similar chicken
sandwiches at another restaurant and they
didn't taste good so I don't think theirs
will be the best either so based on the
example I think you can understand so why
is the person making a generalization
and that's why it's called the Hasty
generalization the second one is slippery slope
uh a slippery slope is uh when a person asserts
that one occurrence leads to another and so on
uh until a terrible conclusion is reached and
uh if we uh take an example of a slippery slope
uh it's the the one that you already have uh on
your screen uh there's this guy who says if I
don't turn this essay on time my teacher will
give me a failing grade if I get a failing
grade I might fail the subject if I fail the
subject I have to take it again next year if
I can't do that I won't be able to graduate on
time so there's that uh very interesting
and uh very good example of a slippery
slope the next one is ADD homonym at hominum
uh is a logical fallacy uh which occurs when
a person uh tries to change the focus of
of an argument from the argument itself to
something about the other person so instead
of let's say attacking the argument or how
strong valid the argument is the person tries
to uh play the person so tries to play uh the
the the speaker and not focusing on the
argument and there's this example uh if
someone supposedly says her whole argu ment
is about taking care of the environment but
he changed the subject by taking about sorry
uh he changed the subject by talking about
how she did poorly in debate competitions
and uh there's a logical fallacy in that
statement and another uh logical fallacy is post
Hawk ero propor Hawk and this fallacy uh or this
conclusion is based based on the idea that if
a came after B then B must have uh caused a so
there's this chain of uh inappropriate logical
relation this logical fallacy is also committed
due to insufficient evidence about the event so
uh the speaker or the writer is trying to shift
their focus into something uh not very important
and jumping to conclusions that are not logical
as uh as we we can see in the example here uh
that says she forgot to bring an umbrella once
and it rained a week later when she brought
an umbrella it didn't rain so she decided to
always bring one so it wouldn't rain how how
smart that is how logical that is and uh and
uh looks like looks like that that's it for
today we uh covered a few uh the most common
logical fallacies that uh are to be seen in
Reading speaking and uh writing passages as
well uh always be critical of what you communicate
because words have integrity just like you do it's
very it's a very good uh advice when it comes
to people who tend to follow or Pursuit a more
academic career or life [Music] and uh if we wrap
wrap this up this whole uh lesson we can review
and conclude by saying that logical fallacies
are common flaws in reasoning that weaken or
invalidate your argument logic your arguments
Logic the four most common logical errors are
Hasty generalization slipper slope at homonym
and post hog Ergo propor hog Hasty General is
when a conclusion is drawn from a study that was
done in a hurry or with insufficient evidence
slippery slope asss that one occurrence leads to
another and so on until a terrible conclusion is
reached and uh ad homm attacks a person rather
than the argument being talked about post Hawk
Ergo propter Haw is based on the idea that if
a came after B then B must have caused a a so
thank you for uh watching this video and uh if you
like this content make sure uh to subscribe like
and comment below if you have any other any other
examples of uh Hasty generalization slippery slob
at homm uh or post hog ero propor hog and thank
you for watching I'll see you next [Music] time